we'll be with you throughout the
preseason orlando come out next this
weekend
man you did not see an awful lot of last
year
trying to turn the corner
[Music]
wide open haywood beyond the ark
[Applause]
steal by hayward it's for basketball
on the catch are you kidding me i'm a
former all-star i'm going hard to the
bucket
elevate reddit williams
hayward taking it right to the basket
for two what a sweet play
kemba walker had a little brush screen
on that that allowed court hayward to
get wide open
hayward off the screen boston has missed
its last seven
before that layup well good job so
short-handed at a couple of positions
jalen brown
out with an illness hayward kicks it out
wide open
tatum and he knocks one down gets the
step patient
gathers himself and knows because
williams trying to go back door passes
picked off by corbin and stolen back by
williams
hayward knocks down a three big time
play by grant williams naval ships and
seedy thank you so much for your service
as sexton
has his shot rejected and back comes
tatum tatum gallops
the foul and gives the hayward gets it
back and lays it in
just about halfway through the opening
quarter
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a good play you see gordon when he
came off the screen along the baseline
they're able to tip the rebound and come
up with it kemba
throws it up oh hey oh nice catch
and then spun it in this is a nice start
for coach porrigo and the hornets here
another turnover here
for charlotte they were to hand tice
with a nice move
and he goes right into the defense of
zeller rozier making a move
his former teammate tyson lost by zeller
in the head
to gordon hayward with the bump and the
bacon he got it to go
count it for two and a foul gordon
hayward makes it work
the open court here you talked about the
39 points versus the cavaliers
just the other day haywood's got loving
a switch now
comes back with a little fall away made
that look very easy
great humility whether we'll see a
different embiid in terms of look out
that b was headed right away i don't
know what happened in the
[Applause]
[Music]
scott and harris stop playing for
the engine out through the former celtic
the blocked by hayward
the call penetrates trying to get it to
ibaka who lost it
boston in transition walker for three
that's a much needed bucket mccall
looking
feed underneath turned over again
heywood there we go
yeah good job by gordon hey we're
getting to that elbow plays inside
so effectively and outside
haywood goes back to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gives it up to williams gets it back
four seconds hayward at the buzzer
[Applause]
something to turn it over he would slow
to get up but he's okay
[Applause]
now we're gonna go quickly the other way
hayward the beneficiary gets two
weaknesses in this bulls team where
where can we attack them
you make adjustments throughout the game
it's just like there's a few things that
they're doing
pretty well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nice pass that's a good pass by ty
skipping it over
jordan hayward knew right away let's get
that ball inside to jaylen brown
take a look brown's working the inside
they go over to gordon hayward and
[Music]
with five on the shot clock makes his
move
little fall away for two
[Music]
there is the best free throw shooting
team in the league
[Applause]
[Music]
nice lead pass brown throws it up
[Applause]
nice finish yeah good elevation by
gordon hayward
oh yeah celsius in transition jalen
brown throws it up for gordon hayward
he's very mild-mannered and very
respectful
green in the lineup nice bounce pass
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
watch this hard drive takes the hit
makes it happen
[Music]
[Applause]
winning eight of nine have dropped six
of their last
eight and they're losing to losing teams
shot clock of three so hayward fighters
and hits
a three-pointer for uh gordon hayward
now walker brings it across with the
lakers back in a hurry hayward
that would have been a goaltend but it
went in five on four
lebron was recovering at the other end
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah good hustle by javonte green
gordon haywood for three hey it only
takes one my grand williams knocked down
the tree in the corner
now the celtics feeling good from
downtown josh hard in the ball game now
that's big now because he's your key guy
got 25 points a game hayward inside and
one
gordon hayward really starting to play
well of late
previous win a couple of nights ago in
orlando let's see
any time that you dribble a basketball
with the celtics they are
they move well without the ball but
hayward is special because that is
just keep an eye on this guy he showed a
lot of
ability in the las vegas summer league
he gave the outlet pass
to hayward entice at the other end
finishes
jimmy butler always a presence
defensively
up top hayward hammers it home on the
lob from marcus smart
stay spread here's gordon hayward
coming on during the early moments
[Applause]
you love going to the line not thinking
about it getting inside dunking
they go to hayward to kind of stabilize
things
he's got chris on a switch and launch
the jumper and hey
gordon hayward three four five six
[Applause]
how about he rolls how about a few rolls
to get him going here
they're just as mentioned dead last in
the nba in field goal percentages
hayward nice move in the paint
thanks to a pretty good job on defensive
rebounding mike
they're shooting 64 from the field right
now
and then add another one now 10 of
from the floor of the lead is six take
you down inside if he can't get to the
rim
he'll fool around with you that reverse
move he loves it
fire there's always been that fire there
but we've added some gasoline to it brad
stevens guys called him
a jet engine coming through the paint
hayward laser gets oh i think that's
the message that brad has been preaching
for the last two days
series of news by tatum
rather by hayward and scores
and harold with the tip of the miss by
green just a moment
ago here's tyce getting inside
one minute remaining second overtime
williams puts the speed on block from
behind by hayward
and last touch by lou williams
play gets beat stays on williams and
knocks it off the glass and it just runs
off
lou williams shoulder and celtic ball
here's smart to hayward and one the
young fella gordon hayward with the dunk
and the foul lord so wide open but smart
there's the pocket path and gordon
hayward being a big
rolling to the basket i love it
that's great basketball early 10-3
blazers lead as you take a look at the
field goal numbers the celtics just
one of six make it two of seven hey
that's your guy
the next cut the boston lead to six we
have 4 27 to go
first half hayward using the tie screen
he cans it along three
oh good defense by haywood
by smart but here it is gordon hayward
look at the solid defense
pull his hands back took the hit blocked
the shot
[Music]
he's taking 13 shots off the bench more
than anybody else on the team hayward
looking for three
[Applause]
pigs to go against a guy like stephen
adams to get him ready for
embiids of the world there's a quick
back throw cut
easy two
[Music]
drills the jumper and we'll get to the
line see the foul on this let's take a
look
there's the screen away
milwaukee middleton can't answer
[Applause]
gordon hayward nice up and under shots
good and won
[Applause]
on shots on jump shots today
you have to be disciplined you have to
be the second
jumper as the defender stay down until
the shooter goes up
and then contest as hard crowder in the
right place at the right time for that
putback
here comes hayward 50 percent shooting
in the first two
driving inside with a two-handed duck
[Applause]
seal hayward just kept dunking robinson
on his backside and was able to get all
the way to the cup with a nice finish
it shows that you have high high
basketball character
and toughness and i think in orlando
mike as hayward knocks into three
he was given an awful team
but what jacques vaughn has talked about
because
next year if he's given the reigns as
hayward knocks down another hayward
stays with it on the offensive class
gets some room baseline and gets two
gordon with a little burst
look at that haywood drive again all
right look at gordon right here
going baseline just elevates we haven't
seen
about three three seconds to shoot
anyone emphatic too
they work up the floor look at this
aggressive drive yes
that's burst right there
eight on the shot clock
[Applause]
which in this case is the game clock
however
[Applause]
ty is passing up the shot double team on
tatum pays off
up for two and a good block haywood
jumping back into the play
i mean he really covers some ground late
get that out of here penalty
gordon hayward elevating smack that
right off the glass
settling for threes not going down right
now before their five field goals have
come in the paint
hayward buries the triple gordon hayward
kimball walker had that one rim out
and here's burke's tried to hit horford
these turnovers are just brutal
it's maddening you see the reaction for
brett brown he's crazed
[Music]
embiid backing down tice gordon hayward
on the help
and they come up with the steal another
76er turnover wanamaker
can't finish whistle foul then tries to
back off and maybe make them travel but
embita is so good
[Music]
hayward from deep got it
[Applause]
new plan for him is to stay here and go
as far as the celtics go
he will be checking his phone at
halftime though mike just to make sure
that robin is not on her way to the
hospital